VQE의 모든 요소를 살펴봤으니, 이제
배운 내용을 정리하고 양자 컴퓨터가 어떻게 실행하는지 알아보자.
먼저 영리하게 선택한 참조 상태, 매개변수화된 circuit,
초기 매개변수 선택, 그리고 해밀토니안으로 시작해.
이걸 양자 컴퓨터에 넘겨줘.
해밀토니안을 ansatz 상태에서 실행하기 전에,
circuit을 고전적으로 전처리해야 해
transpilation이라는 과정을 통해 양자 하드웨어가 읽을 수 있도록 만들기 위해서야.
또한 최대한 활용하는 것도 중요해
실제 하드웨어에서 qubit 아키텍처를 최대한 활용해야 최상의 결과를 얻을 수 있어.
이런 과정들은 보통 자동으로 처리되기 때문에 우리가
qubit 연결성을 직접 알 필요가 없어,
gate 충실도 같은 것들도 마찬가지야.
이제 할 일은 결과 상태를 측정하는 거야
그리고 기댓값을 추정하는 거야, 이건 나중에
고전적 최적화기로 더 최적화돼.
이 측정은 측정 기저를 회전시켜서 수행되고
그런 다음 측정 결과들을 합쳐서 기댓값을 구해.
이 매개변수화된 결과는 그 다음에
고전적 최적화기로 들어가고, 거기서 상태에 대한 새로운 매개변수를 찾아.
그러면 이 과정이 반복돼.
고전적 전처리가 새로운 매개변수화된 circuit을 만들고
이전과 동일한 해밀토니안을 적용해.
전체 VQE 과정에서 우리는 상태만 바꾼다는 점을 주목해
매개변수를 통해서, 이 매개변수들이 바닥 상태에 점점 가까워지는 거야.
결과에 만족할 때까지 이걸 반복해.
그게 전부야.
저는 Victoria Lipinska이고, 이건 변분 양자 고유값 분해기 강좌였어.